The solution to this absolute value in equality is the interval from negative
infinity to negative 7 3rds unioned with the interval from 1 to infinity. let's
see how we got that. When I see an absolute value inequality with a greater than
or equal, I know that I'm going to have a union. Which means that I have to
separate this into two different cases, and connect them with an or. So, I'm
going to write my two cases right here. The first case is, 3x plus 2 is greater
than or equal to 5. It's exactly the same as the original problem, without the
absolute value, and then I need the or. The second case is going to be the
absolute value or 3x plus 2, and we have to switch the direction of the
inequality. And we have to change the sign. So, the absolute value of 3x plus 2
is greater than or equal to 5. Is the same as the compound inequality 3x plus 2
is greater than or equal to 5, or 3x plus 2 is less than or equal to negative 5.
Remember, when we're solving compound inequalities, we need to solve each of
these inequalities independently. So, let's start with this one. I can subtract
2 from both sides, and I get 3x is greater than or equal to 3, and divide both
sides by 3, and I get x is greater than or equal to 1. For the second
inequality, I do the same thing, by subtracting 2 from both sides, And I get 3x
is less than or equal to negative 7. Divide both sides by 3 and I get x is less
than or equal to negative 7 3rds. If I want to draw this on the number line,
we'll put 0 right here. Here's 1. And negative 7 3rds is equal to negative 2 and
1 3rd. To graph x is greater than or equal to 1 on the number line I use a
square bracket and I know I want everything greater than. To graph x is less
than or equal to negative 2 and 1 3rd I go about negative 2 and a 3rd and, since
x is less than. Then I want to go in that directions, and that's how we get our
interval notation here we have negative infinity to negative 7 3rd with a square
bracket because it's less then, or equal to, and I union that with the interval
from 1 to infinity again with the square bracket because it's greater than. Are
equal to. Let's try one more absolute value inequality.